pour la première étape de son voyage aux
États-Unis le président ukrainien a
choisi cet hôpital new-yorkais sont
soignés des soldats Ukrainiens blessés
au front attendu pour la première fois
en personne depuis l'invasion russe à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
volody mirzelinski est interpellé par la
presse
restaurative ou non lorsque le ministre
russe des Affaires étrangères prendra la
parole
je ne sais pas comment cela se passera
mais pour nous
il est très important que tous nos
messages soient entendus par nos
partenaires
et si au sein des Nations Unies il y a
encore une place pour les terroristes
russes
ce n'est pas une question pour moi mais
pour tous les membres des Nations Unies
une question synonyme de pression
diplomatique sur certains pays du Sud
qui ménage Moscou et plaid pour une
solution négociée un an et demi après le
lancement de l'invasion russe parmi eux
le Brésil qui n'a jamais imposé de
sanctions financières à la Russie volo
dumer Zelenski doit justement
s'entretenir avec son homologue
brésilien Lula
dans l'enceinte aux nusienne qui est-ce
pourrait aussi tenter de se rapprocher
du dirigeant turcréchep à hyperdohann
qui tente de ressusciter l'accord sur
les exportations de céréales
ukrainiennes via la mer Noire
volodières ski partira ensuite retrouver
son partenaire numéro 1 à Washington où
il sera reçu à la Maison Blanche jeudi